[Music]
you're watching swine here's a little
taste of what's coming up in the next
ten minutes Thomas finds out how
technology is keeping the Navy ahead of
the enemy meanwhile I'm making music by
tapping various parts of my body and the
wait for Mass Effect Andromeda is over
but of the game deliver hello we've come
to Red Bull studios in London this week
to get a look at a musical instrument
you can wear you know we like to bring
you the unexpected here on swipe but
before we get to that we're gonna catch
up with Thomas he's been in Portsmouth
this week as the Royal Navy begins its
first big exercise of the year with some
cutting-edge technology the Royal Navy
is about to go ultra high-tech in its
largest ever cyber war games the force
will combine artificial intelligence and
unmanned drones to prepare it for war in
the Information Age here in Portsmouth
we got hands-on with a robot used in the
last exercise which was called unmanned
warrior leftenant this looks like a
pretty impressive piece of kit what
exactly is it well it certainly is an
impressive piece of kit this is C fox
it's part of our mine disposal system
that we have on board this is the most
widely used variant a vehicle and is
operated from both the hunt class and
Sandown class mine typers now this is
one system that's used and was used in
unmanned warrior what other systems have
been used in that exercise yes well
whole range of vehicles collectively to
give us that overall picture things like
helicopters but also drones pilot those
drones operated both from the shore and
from ship and other sorts of underwater
vehicles as well this Remus as well as
surface vehicles that are now remotely
controlled and that's really where it's
going to start to progress into the
future smaller surface vehicles which we
can control from ships which we launched
from ships thus keeping the mine hunter
away from the minefield and the
personnel onboard away from the threat
it's this suite of Robotics which was
tested in a major exercise off the coast
of Scotland in October that will keep
the force one step ahead of the enemy
the real strength of a man warrior was
was that breakfast system so we could
work with the providers with the
operators across the whole of the
maritime environment above the water on
the water and under the water to explore
how we might use these systems in future
the exercise starting this week
information warrior aims to build a mind
at the center of warships allowing for
faster more complex decisions to be made
automatically what it does is open up
this window of experimentation so we can
experiment with technology we can get
information kit into the hands of our
soldiers sailors and airmen 2017 is set
to be the busiest year for the Royal
Navy since the end of the Cold War new
ships new subs even a new base
technological innovations being tested
now will allow that force to sell
confidently into the future
Thomas Newton sky news stay with us
still to come I'll be finding out how
that works right after a roundup of this
week's tech news
we heard laptops and devices larger than
a typical smartphone are being banned
from hand luggage on flights to the UK
from six countries in the Middle East in
North Africa it follows a similar
decision in the US where intelligence
services are concerned that electronic
devices could be used to hide explosives
twitter says it removed more than three
hundred and seventy-six thousand
accounts promoting terrorism in the
second half of last year the majority
were apparently identified by the
company's automated technology and Devon
and Cornwall Police is to launch
Britain's first 24-hour drone unit this
summer police chief say remote
controlled devices are cheaper and more
effective when it comes to things like
looking for missing people now what do
you get when you mix a music artist and
a computer programmer maybe something
like this
[Music]
yep he is playing his own sleeve that's
because the shirt is actually a musical
instrument singer-songwriter Tom and
computer coder Brandon created it and
named it that sample shirt create
something that what tech and music
together
it's made with conductive paint and
thread it's like how phone screens work
it can't detect a touch and then and
then so that talks using bluetooth to
Tom's laptop these different notes yeah
well you can you can trigger it to do
anything you can start and stop the
computer you can go to a different
section in the song you can just play a
sample anything you can think of you can
do
prepare mess and created the sample
shirt at Sony Music's buzz jam event
last year set up by the young guns
Network think of it as a cross between a
jam session and a hackathon where music
artists and coders come up with new
instruments could you make trousers for
drummers up-and-coming artists now to be
able to code or to have friends who were
coders I think having coders as makes is
awesome because you can dream up
whatever you have and just put it on the
computer get you made down for the day
get it done and then you're on stage
with something nobody else has what do
you want a kit now we're thinking about
making a tie next possibly yes girls can
wear ties right that's the thing video
games time now and Ross has picked this
week's batch of new titles and here he
is with his thoughts on each one
fans of the Mass Effect series the wait
is finally over Mass Effect Andromeda is
here and it is not going to disappoint
it's the fourth game from this
award-winning franchise and I cannot
wait to play this in more depth I played
the first hour or two of this game and
all I can say is it's definitely been
worth the wait you start off waking up
from a 600 year space journey yes you've
left earth trying to find a new home for
Humanity the planet that you arrived at
hoping that is going to be your new home
doesn't quite look as it did in the
photo but hey it has been 600 years so
you set off with the Pathfinder who is
the man destined to find you your new
home there's also other elements to this
game including a bit of multiplayer but
the main focus is all gonna be around
the campaign something I cannot wait to
play more of and I'm sure once you get
your hands on it you will love it too
if you're a fan of arcade racers then
flat-out 4 is definitely the racer for
you flatout 3-1 also great this game is
going back to its roots and is going to
give you the opportunity to race around
20 different tracks and really just
smash everything up get loads of boosts
smash up your opponents and it's that
true you remember the games like burnout
and gives you that real feeling of fast
paced racing but also fun you're gonna
have that Plus other options within the
racing modes of adding loads of weapons
into it so again not only you destroying
kind of like all the areas that you're
driving through but you're also going to
be destroying all of your opponents with
things like a wrecking ball bombs or
flames and then there is the arena yes
the stadium arena is back and it is down
to you to fling your driver out of the
car in loads of different mini games you
can fling a driver in a game of beer
pong
you can curl him you can do so many
different things in long jump it's just
it's one of those games where you will
want it better your score because you
know your friends will be doing better
than you so overall flat-out for if
you're looking for an arcade racing game
with just fun and fast this is
definitely one you should pick up
American sports in the UK are becoming
far more popular with the likes of
madden and NFL and the American football
and you've also then got basketball
getting bigger and bigger over here with
the NBA but one more game that is coming
out now if you're a fan of baseball in
the MLB then MLB the show 17 is coming
out on PlayStation 4 yes if you imagine
the FIFA of baseball this is the game
that you must have and will want there
is so much to it you will walk into a
room watching someone play this game and
it looks like you're watching the TV it
is that good graphically
many different game modes including
obviously the show which gives you the
chance of getting all the way to the
World Series and taking home the title
of world champions you've got dynasty
mode where you can build your own team
and franchise fill your team with
massive amounts of all-stars if you like
baseball this is the one you've got to
get your hands on and you will not be
disappointed that's it for this week's
episode but don't forget to follow us on
Twitter that's tiny swipe and you can
see what we get up to throughout the
week I'll be back next time I hope you
can join us then but I'm gonna leave you
with Tom's and play us out
[Music]
[Music]